41 seconds of ripped off matrix logos
piece I'm already exhausted the
jumpiness of this futuristic video
editing will serve as symbolism for the
jumpy unstable nough subset futures
government wait a minute this is playing
on specially made screens on tanks for
whom and it's somebody's duty to take a
hologram generating doodad and place it
somewhere randomly just in case the tank
campaign misses a few people which I'm
going to guess is everyone
tell Jeanine we got it oh good an
artifact of great importance of some
sort the vast wall that encloses this
city may protect us from our toxic
surroundings how you built that wall to
keep out toxic do you even science is up
to us to confront any element that could
poison us from within like you I'm
honestly surprised you're still here I
thought you got stabbed or something
last movie though I'll admit to a
certain level of detached attention holy
this thing is on buildings too but why
just these two so this is either
Twilight or Hunger Games I can't
remember birds flying away to signal
something ominous cliche wait I remember
what this is it's Maze Runner isn't it I
was just sitting here thinking this
movie is so much like every other movie
but it really needs a dream sequence to
hammer that home yep no room for three
more small bodies on this floor butter
hanging precariously in the air while
you sleep slackers insurgent remembers
the last movie in bits and pieces just
like real life
okay six minutes in and so far we seen a
bull dream and a mommy flashback cutting
off hair to symbolize some kind of
personal metamorphosis combined with a
bird's flying a way to signify something
ominous cliche to cliches in one
it's a Touche well since we already saw
the bird cliche earlier did someone make
a change to the matrix I like how every
other piece of the zombies highway
overpass is gone or as sprouted grasses
except for this huge half-assed bass
piece what did the future do to
obliterate everything except half of the
support section hey why don't you do
something different hope you did not
we're good you and me I know nothing
else is but we are we skipped a couple
weeks between films so clearly they're
already deeply in love
ironically one of those chores is
watching insurgent how much longer get
to see her fine until we know it's safe
to leave so begins the movies constant
shuffling of hideout locations beginning
with a MIDI she died trying to hide
something from Junaid something there
was entrusted to abnegation Allah Marcus
stop because you're an asshole we can't
possibly listen to this important
information until at least the next
movie I'm not the enemy here but then
who is the Oh also real subtle mr.
director
real subtle however only a divergent can
open this box well isn't that convenient
/ inconvenient find them every last one
of them
first off isn't that what you're trying
to do anyway second off if you find
every last one of them why do you need
this stupid box
can't you just execute them all at once
without some sort of magic Halle baboo
do I really don't know how much longer I
can do this whole peace and love thing
well talking about it this openly in the
amethy lunch line is surely a good idea
also why is the cafeteria Thunderdome
I'll stay with Caleb so that you don't
get him killed two miles teller manages
to play a character that 100% reflects
the rumored character of miles teller
the actor you did your parents we need
to keep our cover here but okay let's do
something that will surely get us kicked
out way before we're ready to leave what
do you think you're doing tragic waste
of Octavia Spencer my office now
man oh but they'll have to write I will
not fight like a hundred times on the
chalkboard after this was I not clear
that the terms of your sanctuary here
included non-violence probably but who
takes that kind of thing seriously one
more chance see to be a MIDI is to
forgive others and yourself hence the
only one more chance thing wait I mean
hence the total forgiveness wait
I mean I'm sending conflicting messages
here all right almost as soon as it
occurs to everyone to look out the
window the takes show up on cue and just
in time to prove Tris right about it up
being safe here the screening technology
from erudite huh son divergent detecting
technology is sudden also they went from
no clue how to tell to super-handy clan
determination machines in about three
months Jesus I need seriously where were
these things the last movie so they're
just my office just my office where I
happen to bring all the fugitives just
before you crash through the village in
a way that asshole miles teller is the
hero of this movie so far either up here
Jesus 100% dick character somehow
achieves 130 percent dick level which is
actually impossible these dumbass kart
also sure let's not have any other
guards anywhere except this one building
and used to total they
really could have been anywhere besides
here or the Thunderdome and easily
escaped oh but there's no reason to run
outside the dome to try and catch them
let's try to shoot them from here it's
more challenging that way movie rips off
the part one from Harry Potter and the
Deathly Hallows what train is on the
save the heroes schedule these heroes
are now running through open ground but
50 bad guys trained in shooting things
will miss them completely yeah no he's
dead and he's clearly going to land
inside the second track here but through
editing that will make it look like he's
Mike Powell
the ironic thing here is those bullets
probably hit something holy Sh I was
just kidding how long were these
assholes gonna hide back here before
they decided to attack the people who
just jumped on so two people just
because they're dauntless can take on an
entire factionless army okay and when we
return suddenly there's like three
factionless people when there were fifty
before so I guess in the first day they
shot this they had plenty of extras then
the next day only three showed up
kailath is frozen while his sister is
attacked which means no matter what
Caleb's choice of side and this
weird-ass war is he's still a terrible
brother why did these assholes come from
Tobias Eaton well you know him I am him
magic code word name ex machina can't
say right now wait for the dramatic
reveal baby underground group of freedom
fighters are gonna save the day cliche
oh man pregnant Mia wants into this
didn't they Tobias mother I sure I'm
glad they establish what kind of
relationship they have surely nothing in
the following events will clue us into
that also are you saying this chick is
his mother despite looking younger than
him on her plates Apple quarters
asparagus carrot sticks and red onion
where's the goddamn broccoli I'm still
your mother no my mother's dead then why
did you so easily call her mother a
minute ago if you're just going to
refuse that she's your mother now were
you overwhelmed by the drama in
exposition we're both a threat to
Jeanine I have no idea what's going on
visit because I have a tragic memory
loss or because this movie is exactly
that forgettable if we were to combine
forces dauntless and factionless we'd be
unstoppable
that sounds pretty made-up are you
talking about pure numbers or actual
trained soldiers are you just bragging
and making it up because I think you are
Tobias please reconsider well that seems
like a reasonable reaction I should've
told you mom did you have time you guys
have been dating for like three days
right and most of that times been spent
running around and in dream sequences
you hardly even know him just like to
think that when you skip this dream
makes me angry
insurgent The Last of Us everyone just
act natural there is not a green screen
behind you but a dystopian wasteland do
not
only think about your characters as
two-dimensional paper cutouts because
that will threaten their one-dimensional
nature here do you think about well you
mean did I kill one last movie no
something must have happened to him he
would have found me by now you know well
I certainly didn't kill him
Jesus get off my fucking back already
would you first off why don't want a
fugitives Tris and four think they can
just walk into any public place without
any kind of precautions whatsoever
second off why didn't their buddy Tory
think boom there might be some people
who aren't so keen on seeing fortress
walk around in public like this I might
want to take them somewhere safe I would
like everyone to know that if Holograms
ever become a thing I give up if I'm
watching TV you're using my computer and
the screen is a hologram
somebody's likely framing me for murder
and would you say that a trial held here
at Kandra would be inherently more fair
than a trial held by erudite sure but
how does candor hold a trial in their
own without the council's blessing you
were all about the rules earlier but not
because four is a field here you go you
can just whip up a trial willy-nilly hey
guys don't mind me I'm just being silly
krumitz on the other side of this class
candor trials are hosted on the set of
Who Wants to Be a Millionaire thank you
for your candor
it was truly dauntless well thank you
everyone knows will right there's only
one will happens to people when they get
close to me
you die what your parents died last
movie as a direct result of your actions
and not because of fate your brother and
boyfriend however are both still alive
and kicking and presumably close to you
I told you that I didn't thank you
yeah like briefly as you were walking
down the hall on the way to the trial
you didn't really have a discussion or a
reason or any real protest so cute so is
this gonna be a thing for real we're
going Christina even an item in the
first movie did I miss that
I mean nobody cares right what the
position are you telling me those six
wires are not only injecting her with
body jerking something's but are also
collectively holding her up in the air
above ground because no assuming that
both
the same no you haven't that was the
sixth test subject who died you
obviously thought each one of them would
be different or else you wouldn't have
ran six tests am I missing something
here I know it sounds crazy but
sometimes I think I see lights out
beyond the wall that sounds totally
crazy dystopian futures rarely ever have
surprising life outside their own
reality with a huge surprise advantage
bad guys decide to shoot grappling hooks
instead of shooting pris who is an easy
target 500 people are shooting at Tris
and they can't even hit her accidentally
thankfully in all movies there is an axe
just inside the door you wish to bar
which just happens to have a convenient
slot for axes instead of those push bars
like nearly every exit door in the world
has what the star of the movie is still
alive sure is lucky this little girl
didn't get curious about all the
commotion at the way after those guys
came through and did their checks why
are we the only ones awake it's for
divergent why don't the people attacking
the compound right now have those little
hologram identification things we saw
earlier and Thunderdome those would have
come in handy as they walked right past
tryst earlier like any world where
someone can fake sleep is one I don't
want to live in it's really good to see
ya Jai Courtney continued - Jai Courtney
these movies with his giant court ninis
oh there it is it's almost like that
entire action scene earlier meant
absolutely nothing since we're in the
exact place we could have been four
minutes ago now at least that guy shared
his thoughts about their possibly being
like beyond the wall before he got shot
movie that has no intention of killing
Tris this early in the series tries to
earn legitimate dramatic tension for the
viewer via a sudden headshot
assassination nope and the suspense of
the scene is completely destroyed since
there's no way they would allow killing
a kid in this movie also let's take a
look at twenty seconds ago shall we this
is how far Tris is away from the kid
there's a bunch of bad guys with guns in
the background and somehow she was able
to get up run and save the kid this skit
definitely broke some ribs except this
is Hollywood so never mind
by the way since when do these things
tabulate the percentage of Palma the
divergence you have earlier this
happened
got one she's what we've been looking
for well white guy thinks he can operate
the hologram thingy better than the
black guy can get her in a vehicle I'll
alert you me why is there some reason
you need to go ahead of your team to
alert Jeanine about someone you've just
taken prisoner and why can't you just
make a phone call it's because of the
plot isn't poor is allowed to attack
this asshole while no one does a goddamn
thing its lucky you got that gun for how
we both know never not sure that one
somehow this Bates four into a fistfight
with Eric because that's constructed
you're responsible for the death of
hundreds of people
how does four know about Terminator
Genisys and as we know Jai Courtney is
responsible for kills the Jai Courtney
character and don't matter how much I
hate these movies I am incapable of not
taking us in off for that and killing
this guy leaves the cleanest floor I've
ever seen in such a situation not that I
know first hand or do I she's still off
the grid yeah but I think I found a
solution and he just happens to be
walking up to us at this very minute
also earlier you told Eric you were
going to alert Jeanine about Tris who
told you about what happened after that
how do you know she escaped and your
mind isn't tris captured and are we here
the solution to get pris to surrender
control the minds of three people and
get them to slowly commit suicide in an
easily saleable situation instead of
like 50 and quicker also why not get all
the people you shot with the sim serum
to gang up on Tris and take her prisoner
why not do it while she's asleep there
seem to be sorry typing in some formulas
here 8500 89 better ways to get Tristan
this high well we know the kid isn't
dying and so he Kravitz isn't dying
so goodbye Blanca you shouldn't have
picked the middle Jesus for didn't even
try to catch this chick are we sure four
isn't the bad guy but wait if people can
be controlled by the tiny silver things
embedded in their skin why didn't the
bosses just control Tris herself who
also has one in her skin yeah she didn't
go to sleep because she's divergent but
the mind control doesn't work either how
inconvenient Marlene her name was
Marlene let me see
nope that still doesn't make me care
it's tendril perhaps around the nearest
major artery try to remove them and they
kill the host
so how hasn't Jeanine already won this
damn war she's got mind-controlling
silver bullet things magic tendrils
goddamn homing beacons and what the
actual Janine
nobody knows about this alliance we have
to protect that advantage this entire
movie so far is over an hour of running
and hiding running and hiding almost as
though they were just trying to buy time
until the third movie
movie with a strong female protagonist
at its center there sure is a lot of
dick-measuring in this then Chris
decides not to tell for about her
terminal cancer diagnosis wait and that
near triple suicide got me hot one in
character who a bunch of people want to
protect sneaks away at night to turn
himself herself in to protect set loved
ones cliche
how did force mom know to be looking out
the window right now this left she's
gone and somehow a trained soldier like
me didn't hear her get up walk around
get dressed and walk out this guy thinks
he can go to headquarters by himself and
save Chris agent open up that box Tris
Tris asks no questions about how the box
is opened but it takes a full agonizing
six seconds for Peter who is expectantly
holding a gun to explain remarkable
chances of it being you of all people
mark was a minor people you've managed
to murder Jesus this line goddammit does
anyone know how to operate guns in these
movies this is clearly going to end up
badly for Peter because he doesn't know
there's such things as distance stop the
suicides are I swear I will shoot him
trans who just sent that terrible line
about it being remarkable how many
people Jeanine has managed to murder
thinks that this one asshole is going to
get her out of this guessing you need me
alive list work movie rips off the
threatened suicide from Hunger Games
waitress discount Fredo Corleone I see
the production designer saw Minority
Report and Matrix Revolutions multiple
times each future technology has no
better way to do this simulation tests
that last movie just had her strapped to
a chair will now require her to be
connected to a dozen snake BOTS Doc Ock
arms that lifts her into the air
divergent simulation steals the plot of
op thank goodness for dreaming Trish she
has the super long rooftop to gain speed
for her jump back up to the burning
floating house did I just say those
words together in a sentence because
that's kind of weird right you see how
this rope is out of her reach here there
is now nothing she can do to get herself
any closer to it she yet she still finds
a way to grab the rope is this a
simulation of real life or is it a
simulation of a video game
breehn Tris is basically spider Glenn
come on this is a movie or a Mario
Brothers level her mom looks
surprisingly unburned for having been in
the structure completely engulfed in
flames for the last three minutes even
in a simulation this metal pipe should
be burning her skin off completely at
this point twisting her mom randomly
jump off a crumbling piece of wall and
land safely because somehow even Kate
Winslet looks pissed at this bolt also
included in the simulation is a
realistic recreation of what it's like
to hug your mom can't
come please oh wait really that's all
she had to do was open up to her mom
about not wanting to be divergent
anymore that passed the test I mean
really it's during this Star Wars
inspired hallway escape shootout that I
realize this movie has shown me nothing
some imaginary bull a crapload of
running high while being chased and a
few predictable gotcha moments you are
so Tris is going to pass the area died
portion of the sim here but why does
this fake for death take 30 seconds of
time it's neither real nor matters we've
got it wrong subtle variation honor you
better come take a look at this cliche I
just went through some shower your
mother's death just like your
boyfriend's death will mean absolutely
nothing after everything she's been
through Tris still lets herself be
manipulated by unoriginal button-pushing
movie simulates what it's like to watch
this movie no movies going to waste a
lot of time trying to make us think Tris
is dead first I swiped a paralytic from
the infirmary and I shot her up when she
was all freaking out about you yeah but
she still went through the simulation
right she still failed it still got
killed at the exact moment she fell into
the streets of the fake city how does a
paralytic work under your precise timing
standards and prevent the simulation
death when I survive make sure we do all
right
pg-13 movie just wasted it's f-bomb on
that seriously that says more about
these movies that I really think it
oughta this asshole was last known to be
with the target and is somehow allowed
to just saunter back in and resume his
station without so much as a what's up
and because of that oversight he
immediately goes to work helping the
good guys
does Jeanine run the sloppiest evil
outfit ever or what oh wow that's
amazing
you can simply take a prisoner and move
him into the admin folder that's
ridiculously convenient the computer
doesn't even wonder why you're doing
that
either I finally found a way to get him
out safely how many others every last
one
we waited until everyone got them
removed before telling you our leader
about them also how she got these things
which wrap around the nearest major
artery taken out is of no concern just
know that she did it and it probably
involved unseen genies you're gonna
fight her the one you really hate the
biggest obstacle hero faces is him or
herself cliche the only problem with
anything goes universes is that book
like this happens where the main
character has to fight herself and the
entire thing is so fake feeling that I
missed the conclusion because I was out
in the lobby waiting for my date to
finish watching the film and exit the
auditorium Oh what
people who made this simulation forgot
to add realism I was going to think this
is really happening when the whole
goddamn floor gets knocked out after a
single punch doesn't this mean she fails
the Amity test and no one will ever ever
forgive you for what you've done
seriously how is this test hard to pass
you know for a fact you're in a
simulation fight between main character
and herself is undercut a bitch dramatic
wait by all the fakeness these will be
the divergent they are the true purpose
of this experiment why did the
simulation kill people who didn't do
certain things right I can't just fail
the subject and not open the box no
actionless ex machina wait and her name
is Evelyn as an evil Lin or you know
just plain evil okay I guess I can see
where this is going so it was all set up
now come outside the wall to learn the
real truth man I know it's an easy joke
to compare the Maze Runner series to
this one but god damn I had no idea they
were actually this similar Jesus did the
two authors compare notes while writing
how much you want to bet the outside the
wall people aren't only appear to be
people who've just been told they were
guinea pigs in a big experiment now just
willingly walk toward the wall like
there's nothing left to distrust in the
world they're all like what's that my
whole world is a lie I can't wait to
find out what's next the most inspiring
way to end this movie was obviously an
incredibly fake looking CGI sweep over a
CGI landscape with little CGI people
running below from off-screen dinosaurs
or something I'm so fucking uplifted
right now who knows what's out there
you'll never find out
Naomi Watts shoots Kate Winslet I'm
pretty sure this is Australia getting
back at England for something probably
the prison colony thing
virgins will destroy our society
two men enter one man leaves you can
sugarcoat it on nothing is too messed up
that can't be fixed with a Peter Gabriel
song I like that version as much as the
next girl does yes this whole thing oh
man even though you had freaking cancer
you're willing to give money to a
corporation for the chance to acquire
even more cancer my secret
may the truth set you free the truth
shall set you free you do Jack huh what
do you do you're so smart right yet have
a guy with a plan cuz I'm smart son
smarter at you Marlene
her name was Marlene his name is Robert
Paulson
his name is Robert Paulson
but I am serving the greater good all
about the greater good you of course
you're not you can defeat me Scott but
can you defeat yourself nigga Scott
biggest God
I'll be damned I don't know that I
believe anyone's 100% a dick man have
you ever had a friend who knows exactly
what you want and surprises you with an
awesome personalized present you can
look inside if you really want to well
that is exactly what Luther it is to us
they've supported youtubers since they
first started shipping their monthly
crates full of epic geek gamer and
pop-culture items wait
routing klingon dutch yogurt dude for
less than $20 a month you can receive
six to eight items that include bison
skier apparel collectibles unique
one-of-a-kind items and more look what I
got in August from the villains to great
you have until the 19th at 9 p.m.
Pacific to subscribe and receive that
month's crate and when that cutoff
happens that's it it's over icons ow
wait gonzo sign up at loot crate calm
slash cinemasins and enter the code
cinemasins to save 10% on any new
subscription / if you sign up before
september 19th at 9 p.m. Pacific
Standard Time you'll receive the summon
rate say I get to buy case again you
guys want badass memorabilia apparel and
other gear especially created and
curated for gamers and geeks sign up at
loot crate calm slime cinemasins and
enter code cinemasins to save 10% on
your news from Scripture